an elite group of men can [__] a lot of
women the initial encounters where men
come together with women we're not even
talking about relationships now that
initial moment when they meet who's
usually going to be more pickier who's
going to be more willing to settle with
whatever comes their way wherever they
catch that night or sex it's not in that
initial moment when you first come into
contact with the opposite sexier who is
usually more picky is it gonna be men or
women when you think of the sex men are
gonna be less picky than women of course
men will [__] tells you said you
don't think that's where it starts like
wanting to sleep with the person